Welcome to today's hot topic from
intelligence squared.com.
Too much free speech kills the massacre
in Arizona.
Shows that the USA must learn from
Europe to curb hate speech.
Do you agree?
The Lone gunman who mowed down Gabrielle
giffords was mentally disturbed,
but were the outcomes of his ravings
caused by the climate of political
hostility.
Sarah Pailin,
for example,
had placed gunsight icons on Gifford's
congressional district.
Does this mean she shares in the
responsibility for what happened in
Britain?
Politician filled Willis was stripped of
his seat and his party membership for
the kind of polarizing language.
That's an everyday occurrence in the
USA.
So who has got it right?
Does liberal democracy need you to get a
thick skin or does it need a strong
state protecting us from extreme verbal
assault?
Here are some highlights from Wendy
kaminer confronting Femi autogenous as
they thrash it out.
We start with femi defending curbs on
hate speech.
Less,
less hate will be bread,
and so we would have less fear.
I think that hate speech can certainly
be a contributing factor to bigotry and
prejudice.
And I'm,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not here defending the merits of
hate speech,
but I,
I,
you know,
as I said,
I think it is always much more dangerous
and I also think that it's morally wrong
to criminalize speech that we don't like
because we have some sense that in the
long run it's going to be,
it's going to cause societal harm.
People should be given the right to
speak yes to the point where it violates
the rights of others.
People may be given the right to express
their concerns about principles,
but not about individual characteristics
that people I'm grateful and proud to
live in a country and to be part of a
nation that does not tolerate hate
speech is if anything that perhaps our
restrictions and hate speech have go far
enough.
If I can take this opportunity to
respond quickly to some of the things
that the first day I really appreciate
her forthrightness in questioning why we
need to have freedom of speech.
Because that's not a statement that you
will generally hear from people in the
US who defend hate speech regulation.
Because here,
um,
it's not really so acceptable to say,
I don't believe in free speech.
Please visit intelligence squared.com to
see a full selection of our performances
and debates on free speech.